le changement climatique est un immense
défi fond c'est quasiment un himalaya
affranchir de lutter contre le
changement climatique ou d'en limiter
les effets pour relever ce défi immense
on a besoin d'associer les citoyens
parce que ça vient interroger
réinterrogée notre modèle de comptes de
sociétés notre modèle de consommation
nos demandes et de l'alimentation notre
modèle de logements et c'est bien
l'objectif de la convention citoyenne
qui a été voulu par le président de la
république que de faire en sorte que les
citoyens puissent se saisir de ces
questions que puissent ensuite les
parlementaires parce que c'est leur
légitimité traduire dahmane d'une
manière législatives le gouvernement
pour sa part le traduit d'un point de
vue réglementaire ce que sont les
orientations et les objectifs qui
doivent permettre de réduire d'au moins
40% à l'horizon 2030 on n'opère pas des
changements de cette nature si on
n'arrive pas à convaincre les 66
millions d'habitants du défi que nous
avons devant nous de l'importance de
charge des changements que ça peut
produire est au fond aussi du caractère
enthousiasmant de ce défi parce que ça
vient réinterroger notre modèle de
société ça peut le réinterroger
positivement ça peut produire de la
croissance
ça peut produire des transitions qui
fasse qu'on regarde autrement le monde
dans lequel on vit qu'on ait une
mondialisation qui sont d'une nature
différente qui soit plus respectueuse de
son environnement de la biodiversité
lieu du pas la préservation des
ressources parce que la seule exigence
est que nous puissions transmettre aux
générations futures une planète qui soit
vivable et en même temps c'est très
enthousiasmant parce que je pense que ça
vient réinterroger utilement notre
manière de vivre et au fond c'est un
formidable enjeu politique il ya lieu de
s'en réjouir